we uh we have yet another sort of four
seasons
hotel versus four seasons total
landscaping
moment from the now former trump
administration
the guardian is reporting that an
italian restaurant
owner was sanctioned by trump and put on
a blacklist
and it has made his life a complete and
total nightmare this is just a mistaken
identity case trump sanctioned
the wrong guy alessandro batsoni
owns a restaurant in the northern
italian city of verona
beautiful part of italy alessandro
batsoni
was sanctioned by the trump
administration crackdown
on blacklisted venezuelan crude oil
the u.s treasury also mistakenly
blacklisted
sari graphic lab a graphic designed
company
owned by another man also named
alessandro batzoni
in sardinia and that business owner
that alessandro bozzoni confirmed that
his company was hit with sanctions
they declined to comment further so what
is this all about
in 2019 trump's government
put in sanctions on venezuela's state
oil company
called petroleos de venezuela pdvsa
the attempt here was to try to get
maduro nicholas maduro
to resign the president of venezuela and
on his last day in office trump
sanctioned a network of oil films
firms and individuals connected to the
venezuelan oil company
but sony who's the restaurant owner in
italy
discovered his company's name amg
sas d alessandro bazzoni
was on the blacklist when he went to his
bank in january the day before trump
left office
and he was told his accounts had been
blocked he thought it was a joke
he said kovid it's already really
difficult for restaurant owners now i
don't even have access to my money what
the hell is going on
now he said he was able to solve the
problem
by dealing directly with the us
government and said
he managed to get a visa until 2023
and it was resolved he got no apology
he got no explanation but his name
ultimately was removed
from the list multiple alessandro
bazonis
having their companies sanctioned by
trump
because of an error now i believe this
was no accident what i believe happened
is that trump went to this italian
restaurant
and he was expecting unlimited
breadsticks like you get at olive garden
and the owner said sir this is a real
italian restaurant
unlimited breadsticks give me a break
trump was furious
and he vowed revenge which came now
that's a joke
what i really think happened is as usual
with the trump administration
incompetence in the execution
of already bad ideas that that would be
how i would summarize what took place
here
it seems as though at least one of two
alessandro betsony's
was able to get this all taken care of